I'm just concerned that
these bacon strips are big.
I didn't realise
what they were for.
Ugh. Yeah.
You know, do we want
to eat a big chunk of bacon
in our frittata?
At least
it's not real bacon.
-It's turkey.
-No, I know. But the size.
When we eat it, we don't
want, like, this huge chunk.
-Yeah.
-I wanted half this size.
I think it's bigger
than an inch.
Should I take them out
and try to cut them?
I don't know.
Try.
Don't like burn yourself.
-OK, can I trust you to…
-Yeah.
-…watch this for a minute?
-Yes.
-And I'll be right back.
-Yeah, perfect.
-OK.
Alright. It's…
They're looking good.
Very tan.
I feel like
you can put the eggs in.
I just don't know
if I trust you.
Do you feel like
you're cooking with North?
Or is she a better cook
than I am?
It's definitely just as fun.
Yes.
Nice. Baby bacons.
So we just pour
this in it says?
Yeah.
Nice.
-OK.
-And then, like, mix.
Half a cup of Parmesan.
-That's a lot.
-I know. Over the top.
You're not supposed
to leave this
in the middle
to cook in here.
Oh.
Yes.
Transfer to oven.
-Hell yes.
-OK.
Loves it.
And that's hot, literally.
I'm so happy that we learned
how to make this.
Yeah, I'm sure you're gonna
be doing it over and over.
Well, next year
when I'm married
and having babies,
I will be doing this.
I'm just so excited I know
how to make a frittata.
So 12 minutes. OK.
So if it were me,
in my kitchen,
this is when you take
the 12 minutes to clean.
OK.
Cooking tip.
Kitchens
don't clean themselves.
Bummer.
You want to put it
all in the dishwasher?
Is this clean stuff?
I don't know.
Are they the same thing?
-So…
-This is a bit messed up.
-Crystals?
-Don't put that in there.
-That's hand-wash, right?
-Yeah.
You are so responsible.
Really?
I have to clean as I go.
OK, this burnt stuff,
I don't know where this--
I'm learning a lot today.
Where's the trash?
Right next to
the whatever it's called.
Dishwasher.
Oh, yeah,
we should put the timer on.
Oh, yeah.
I feel so grown up,
so responsible,
like a hot housewife.
Literally.
I don't know.
Was that really 12 minutes?
No idea.
Oh, my God,
it smells so good.
-Is it raw still or is it…?
-I don't know.
I didn't know eggs
could turn into that cloud.
Yes. We did it.
-You hungry?
-I am.